hello and welcome to this video playing
lotus eater I am lotuseater who is that
no name Wow ok I wanted to play the
green felt and now I have to play
against the mega exciting in London
system ok I'm going for a double hearing
kettle or a red tea set up something
that I have played quite a bit over the
years with both colors actually aha see
going for me for what is the point maybe
now maybe it's going i can take on d4
and on FYI guess if he goes you form as
some tactics going on my idea is to go
Queenie aid control yeah i was thinking
that this isn't possible I mean maybe it
is possible but I thought it isn't great
I thought Knight takes e4 now is an
issue you can take on air seven though
this is somewhat somewhat murky at least
Jim this is the way to to do it them not
you know no other move can can try to if
you reform yeah I thought he takes on f7
hmm overlooking something this feels
just just like a porn and I've got the
bishop pair on top of it weird I thought
you would take on f7 like this which at
least keeps material equality oh I'm out
we're looking some kind of tricky I
don't don't see it here night to D to
marry and then taking on yourself this
is something yeah I can play night e 22
can take f3 maybe it's not white resigns
oh really yeah i was thinking this may
be to attack here and here but i can
take f3 this is a good reply I can't
take this route takes the form and
Knight takes rook is not detect any more
than I can keep my pawn and this
position is indeed very good for black
I've got the pawn and um his isolated
pawn deform is a problem i have stuff
like Queen to be seven rook c8 maybe
Queen 25 and this Bishop on h2 is a
pretty bad piece yeah I was really a bit
wondering why it didn't check on f7
witches well kind of obvious otherwise
you're just a pawn down k and this is
not totally clear position I was
thinking I should be ok but I wasn't
totally sure because well 95 is a big
threat have to go age six and this is
also look
slightly slightly dues however I've got
some stuff in my favor bishop pair very
good bishop p.m. and this bishop on h2
is mostly looking at a very soundly
protected pause so this is not a good
piece on h2 yeah I mean I think black is
certainly okay but it's not like I'm
winning or anything the engine is on on
roughly equal evaluation which seems
fair because I have some problems here
the bishop has knives and so on but then
many weaknesses and the position is not
clear at all this is what he what he had
to do it but surprise me that he just
took there after which she just seems to
be a porn down for no particular
compensation yeah a very short game what
I can recommend is this kind of setup to
play against the white london system if
you play a fine kettle paste defense
like the Greenfeld or the Kings Indian
defense this is a possible setup that
you can choose just to fianchetto both
bishops and play in the style of the
reti opening trying to long-term play
something like the bishop up here Queen
should be seven so that there is some
pressure on the diagonal and possibly
beehive can be played I think black has
basically equalized him here's a port
down compared to the to the wide opening
the Reggie opening but that the tempo
down is not it's not that relevant so we
are talking more about a set up base
thing than then you move by move tempo
sensitive opening blackest black is okay
here and i think has pretty much
equalized already okay well thanks for
watching